welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and is the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the dimension numerical
designation of 616 or 199 999 the recent
trailer for Spider-Man across the
spider-verse just weighed in on this
debate with a bold stance from Miguel
O'Hara what's the guy I gotta do to join
this spider team you can never be part
of this don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999.99 616 is considered the
designation for the home Marvel Universe
in the comics and in 2018 Spider-Man
into the spider-verse 616 was listed on
their screen to show the contrast to the
universe of Miles Morales Spider-Man
1610 and all the universe numbers we see
in these animated movies match the
comics exactly but this contradicts the
line from Doctor Strange to the
Multiverse Madness when Christine Palmer
from the 838 Universe told the MCU
Stephen Strange that his home reality
was 616. our universe is 838 and we've
designated yours 616. wow
we've got some
got some around naming realities a very
very super Marvel Studios because for
many years the MCU had been known as
199.99 a distinctly different Universe
from the home Universal the comics 616.
but over the years the MCU has begun to
mention 616 more and more and today's
video is sponsored by Babel one of the
top learning language apps in the world
Babble specializes in preparing you for
real-life encounters and situations and
new rockstars we've been using Babel for
a while now and it's great Studies have
shown that 15 hours of using Babel is
the equivalent of a semester of college
Spanish and 15 hours in Babel flies by
like nothing you can watch videos listen
to podcasts play games or do sessions
whatever kind of learning mood you're in
Babel's got something that fits the bill
you're learning but it's gamified enough
to be legit fun too I have daily goals
and achievements I can unlock as I learn
the language at this point I've been
using battle long enough that I've
leveled up from the Hello Goodbye please
and thank you stuff to the more
interesting things like CM Freight
Las palomitas
so get 60 off your subscription when you
click the link in the description or
scan the QR to start learning with
battle today like Loki episode 1 had a
TBA film strip of Loki's life in the
infinity Saga labeled 616 in Spider-Man
far from home Mysterio Quentin Beck said
there are multiple realities Peter this
is Earth Dimension 616 I'm from Earth
833 616 was written on Scott Lang's
storage locker in Avengers end game 616
was one of many things written on Eric's
selvic's chalkboard and Thor the Dark
World though you could say those last
two might have just been set designer
Easter eggs and many Marvel Comics fans
point to Quentin beckbean a liar and say
that the TVA and Christine Palmer might
just be lying or mistaken that the TBA
was one massive con anyway so they can't
really be trusted and Christine Palmer's
numbering system will just be how she
and the Baxter Foundation categorize the
realities of the Multiverse and that
doesn't make 616 the true objective
number of the MCU they point to examples
in the comics that reference the
live-action movies as a separate
Universe within the same Multiverse of
the comics like in 2013's Young Avengers
Vol 2 number eight a passport shows
their Passage through the Multiverse
which includes a stamp from Earth 199
999 this has also gone the other way in
the first Captain America film kids read
the exact issue of Captain America
number one from 1941 exactly as it looks
in the comics Iman villani the mcu's
Kamala Khan weighed in on this after
Multiverse of Madness came out I like to
say that's 616. I don't believe that the
MCU is 616 as much as Kevin feige can
make us think that it's 616. it is one
nine nine nine nine nine Milani went on
to say in other interviews all this
happened because Kevin feige made a joke
in an interview about how long the MCU
would stand for and he said 199 999
years but we need a number and you can't
take it from the Marvel Comics Canon
because that was like the main Comics
Canon where all the main events took
place I was actually able to ask him on
villani about this last year all right I
gotta ask you I read the Reddit AMA
where he said that after you said that
MCU wouldn't be 616 on the red carpet
that I guess Kevin feige saw you the
next day and stared you down and just
went like
and walked away
[Laughter]
think about that every day it's I
I get it I get it I guess he makes
decisions that's fine he's done a great
job I'm just trying to you know it's
convenience now you have to specify
Comics one six versus MCU 616 and I'm
just trying to save everyone's breath
you know like like it's a lot
now you may be watching this wondering
why are people so pissed off about this
well for villani and many others it's
just confusing Marvel Comics have used
616 for the primary Earth since 1983. a
captain Britain's storyline written by
David Thorpe who in 2020 was asked by
marvel.com how he came up with a
numbering system for the different
universes and he said obviously it has
something to do with 666 the Number of
the Beast 666-50 well there you have it
as always Mephisto was behind it all
goodbye everybody
but where did 199 999 come from well
vilani cited a joke that Kevin feige
supposedly made and there is a lot of
chatter on social media about Kevin
feige supposedly joking that he wanted
the MCU to run for 199 999 years but I
can confirm to you all watching that
that is not true there is literally no
record anywhere of Kevin feige ever
saying that no interview no Reddit AMA
no convention speech no investor call no
red carpet remark nothing hidden under
that ball cap I checked everywhere some
say 199 999 might come from the year
1999 when the first X-Men movie began
shooting which is where Kevin feige got
his start as an associate producer but
if that's true why would he just
randomly add two nines also Kevin
feige's work on that movie began long
before principal production began in
September 1999 development for that
movie began years before that and also
would he just care more about the
release year of 2000 no this 199.99
years quote is the complete myth that
originated with one Reddit post I found
in 2017 that every article and social
media post ever since has echoed without
bothering to verify you can actually
Google the phrase in quotes
199999 years and there is literally zero
mention of Marvel or 5G before 2017 but
there was a book published by Marvel
Comics the January 2008 edition of the
official Handbook of the Marvel Universe
which lists what was then the upcoming
2008 Iron Man movie as Earth 199 999
that's it one reference book published
by a different division of Marvel
entertainment that likely had little
understanding ending of the complex
world the MCU would grow into Kevin
feige himself certainly didn't and
that's why we don't have any real feggy
quote about this it came from a division
of Marvel that he had nothing to do with
and he's the one who keeps getting asked
about it I think by making these 616
references Kevin feige wants to claim
the Cinematic Universe says the primary
source Universe a film adaptation of the
main universe of the comics he wants
people to think it's the same thing but
in movies but that is the frustration
Comics fans feel because for people who
found their way into Marvel through the
MCU titles it's no big deal number it
whatever you want but for readers who
found their way in through Comics issues
before they were adapted into films
labeling the movie Universe 616 might
feel like it's demoting the importance
of the source material that they grew up
reading as if these pages are not the
true version of the overall narrative
these readers feel that the comics are
the pure gospel with a numbering system
that already works and that Kevin feige
is a temporary Steward of this current
ERA of film adaptations that represent
just one interpretation of their
scripture now you see this less with
readers of a franchise like Harry Potter
when those books return into movies but
Harry Potter doesn't have a meta
Multiverse numbering system in which the
books and movies reference each other as
distinct timelines and also those films
were coming out as the book series was
still being written and they don't
seriously diverge from that narrative
it's all one thing in fans minds but not
the case for Marvel the MCU could have
X-Men or Fantastic Four for many years
and they still have rules about how much
they can feature Spider-Man and Hulk the
movies just had to make different
choices with the narrative Civil War and
the MCU is just not the same thing as
civil war in the comics it's not even
close so is the MCU 616 or is it 199 999
who's right Christine Palmer or Miguel
O'Hara well here's what I know I know
Sony doesn't get to decide what the MCU
calls itself I know 199 999 is a pretty
random number that feige himself never
said I know Universal numerical
designations only matter to characters
outside of that Universe because if
you're in a universe to you it's just
home and I know that if Christine Palmer
can be wrong so can Miguel O'Hara so
here's what I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
the MCU is neither 616 nor one nine nine
nine nine nine and it will not have
earned the status of 616 until after
Avengers Secret Wars when Kevin feige
can do a clean reboot of the franchise
with a proper lineup of Fantastic Four
and mutants and Spider-Man and a new
Tony Stark a movie 616 that actually
looks like the comics 616. until then
Marvel Studios can call itself 616 but
many of us will place beside that 616 a
tiny little asterisk that will link down
to a footnote that we'll read not yet
April 21st will begin my rewatch series
of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1 and
volume 2 over on the Deep dive channel
so please subscribe and keep an eye out
for those videos you're going to love
them support our growing Network by
grabbing something from our merch store
nerd riot.shop subscribe to new
rockstars on YouTube and on all social
platforms you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at EA boss thanks for
watching bye
thank you
[Music]